another story huh
one where the very fate of pandora hangs
in the bounce
if not too bad i'm telling you anyway
first there was the vault an alien
prison opened with a mystical key
to the warriors who opened it the vault
was just a container of tentacles and
disappointment
they vanished into the wastelands
certain that the vault held no treasure
at all
they were wrong
the vault's opening triggered the growth
of iridium a priceless alien element
soon the rare and valuable mineral
emerged all across pandora its
appearance attracted many including the
hyperian corporation
they came to pandora to mine iridium and
bring order to the savage planet
through their excavations hyperion
uncovered evidence of an even greater
vault
their leader vowed to find it to use its
power to civilize the borderlands once
and for all
but hyperion weren't the only ones
searching for the next vault's alien
power
the call of danger and loot is not so
easily resisted
certain warriors came to pandora in
droves to uncover its hidden secrets
some would call them adventurers
others call them fools
but i
call them vault hunters
our story begins with them
and with a man
named handsome jack
uh
oh
[Music]
[Music]
but i know
[Music]
it
this is
[Music]
[Music]
this is
[Music]
[Music]
it's cute that y'all think you're the
hero to this little adventure but you're
not
welcome to pandora kiddos
great another deadbolt hunter handsome
jasmine busy
wait a minute you're not dead
yes
now i can get off this glacier claptrap
your metaphorical ship has finally come
in
allow me to introduce myself i am a
cl4ptp stewardbot but my friends call me
claptrap or they would if any of them
were still alive or had existed in the
first place oh i've got something for
you
here take this echo communicator that i
totally didn't loot from one of these
corpses it comes with a class 12 heads
up display complete with a mini map now
hunter
i can finally join the resistance and
sanctuary
so i stop thinking out loud
i wonder what it's like to have a belly
button
i'll explain everything soon but know
this
you're alive for a reason
and i
am here
well done your ability to walk short
distances without dying will be handsome
jack's downfall
and open
just a little added security gotta keep
those bully moms at bay or they'll rip
your eyes out
sorry about the mess everything jack
kills he dumps here bandits balls
hunters claptrap units if i sound
pleased about this it's only because my
programmers made this my default on a
voice i'm actually quite depressed
now the creatures around here are
dangerous none more than this bully long
named knuckle dress killed everyone i
know
anywho i keep a pistol in the cabinet
over there for emergencies but and here
we should be pretty sick
wow
[Music]
the gun the gun is a cabinet
once upon a time